الثالث ملك بريطانيا واربعه عشره دوله
اخرى في الكومنواف بعد ان انتظر اكثر من
70 عاما لاستلام العرش اثر وفاه والدته
الملكه الثانيه في سبتمبر الماضي وهي اطول
فتره من قبل واريث العرش في التاريخ
البريطاني
هو الاسم الكامل عند ولادته في قصر عام
1948 وهو الابن البكر للملك الراحله
وزوجها الامير فيليب اصبح وليا للعهد منذ
كان عمره ثلاث سنوات على عكس اسلافه تلقى
الملك تشارلز تعليمه في المدارس العامه
وكان اول افراد الاسره الملكيه من يحصل
على شهاده جامعيه في عام
1969 توج تشارلز رسميا بلقب امير وينز في
مراسم قلدته فيها والدته الملكه اليزابيث
تاج امراء
على خطى والده استكمل الملك تشارلز خدمته
العسكريه واصبح الطيارا في سلاح الجو
الملكي كما التحق بدوره في الكليه البحريه
الملكيه قادته الى مهمه على متن مدمرات
وفرقطات
في عام
1981 تزوج تشارلز اول مره من الليد دايان
سبنسر الارستوقراطيه والمعلمه في روضه
اطفال في حفل تاريخي وصف بزفاف القرن
العشرين انجب الاميرين ويليام هاري لكن
قصه الحب تحولت بعد سنوات الى كابوس
وانتهت بطلاق الزوجين بسبب علاقه تشارز
الغراميه لفتره طويله مع كميلا باركا بولز
ما ادى الى تراجع شعبيته حينها في العام
2005 عقد تشارز وكاميلا قرانهما في حفل
زفاف مدني متواضع في وينزر
[موسيقى]
القويه حول مجموعه من القضايا بما فيها
السياسيه على عكس الحياد لدى العائله
الملكيه الى جانب اهتماماته بالهندسه
المعماريه والزراعه العضويه وحمايه البيئه
ارائه تسببت في تعرض الانتقادات من قبل
البعض لكن اخرين معجبون بتفهمه والتزامه
ويرونه شخصا مخلصا قضى حياته في الدفاع عن
القضايا التي يؤمن بها وغالبا ما يوصف
بانه ملك فيلسوف بسبب فضوله الفكري
واهتمامه بمجموعه من القضايا
[موسيقى]
الملك تشارز الثالث في سباق للترك بصمتها
الخاصه في تاريخ الملكيه البريطانيه خصوصا
وانها لن تكون طويله على غرار المده التي
قضتها والدته في الحكم بالنظر الى عمره
مصطفى العربيه لندن لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات